hallo leute hier wieder eure mal waren
und heute täglich etwas ganz besonderes
und zwar das ramadanfest juni von den
mitgliedern kam vor ein paar tagen auf
mich zu und abgefragt vanessa möchtest
du nicht ramadan fasten ausprobieren und
ich sagte ja warum nicht ich mache jetzt
nicht die komplette ramadan zeit mit
sondern nur vier tage aber die dann auch
richtig happy über eine liste mit regeln
bekommen die ich mich halten muss
während der fastenzeit kein essen keine
tränen keine zigaretten kein kaugummi
oder sonstige konsummittel und kein
geschlechtsverkehr und jetzt kommt ein
ganz wichtiger punkt fünf mal am tag
muss ich mir sonst minuten zeit nehmen
und beten oder meditieren oder daran
denken wofür ich zum beispiel dankbar
bin oder mich über den ramadan
informiert eine weitere wichtige regel
für die fastenzeit streit vermeiden und
nicht schlecht über andere und die
vorsichtsmaßnahmen und auch ganz wichtig
bei übelkeit und kreislaufprobleme muss
man ab rechnet man krank ist und an die
periode hat oder wenn man anfängt sich
zu übergeben dann muss man es abbrechen
weil das soll man ja auch nicht wenn
seine gesundheit ja nicht schaden dem
glauben zur fastenzeit ramadan und es
gibt wieder ein paar aufgaben soll alles
blocken in den nächsten vier tagen muss
sich mindestens einmal einen bedürftigen
ernährt habe und eine aufgabe die mir
wirklich schwer sein wird ich freue mich
mit freunden treffen zum essen und nicht
öffentlich lockt mit dieser aufgabe für
mich auch einfacher ärger bevor ich mir
jetzt die nächsten minuten beim hungern
zu schauen könnt wollte ich euch noch
ganz kurz die zeiten sagen dass morgen
früh um 436 daten noch essen und trinken
ab von 30 muss ich die erste meditation
machen 13 06 ungefähr kommt das nächste
bab 17 uhr 29 das nächste klein und 20
uhr 25 darf man dann fastenbrechen
natürlich wieder verbunden mit einem
gebiet und dann nochmal um 23 uhr 21
noch mal darüber nachdenken worüber ich
nicht alles dankbar bin
und jetzt bleibt mir nichts mehr anderes
zu sagen außer dass wird die hunger
spiele beginnen
es ist gerade zwei uhr 25 80 stunden mit
essen haben und es ist 236 es geht los
gestern morgen an dem ich nicht
frühstücke und ich denke jetzt schon die
ganze zeit das abendessen ein schönes
muster auch nicht müde frutti wird
mittlerweile halb drei und ich bekomme
wirklich hunger ich denke ganze zeit
darüber nach was ich gern essen würde
sonst habe ich noch nicht so wirklich
appetit ob pommes mit majo rom
es ist jetzt neun uhr und in 25 minuten
darf ich wieder was trinken und das
essen zum 12
erster tag das so erhält die ihm gemacht
da hab ich gedacht ist hier das hält man
auch nicht essen nicht trinken
aber so ab 16 uhr ergibt schon los
[Musik]
ich war gerade essen und ich hab's
vergessen zu filmen weil ich etwas nur
den teller bekommen habe und eingeholt
habe es plötzlich das beste outfit
nehmen wir uns für ihn und weit über
ramadama dann ist der fastenmonat der
muslime und neunten monat des
islamischen mondkalenders in ihm wurde
nach islamischer auffassung der koran
herab gesandt im 9 monats ist ja wie bei
einer schwangeren frau würde ich
wirklich bin
drei stunden lang sah mich noch etwas
trinken einzige was mich gerade wirklich
nervt ist dass ich nicht ins bett gehen
kann obwohl es irgendwie 10 42 ist weil
ich will dich ins bett gehen und eine
halbe stunde wieder aufzustehen ich habe
ganz vergessen zu sagen dass ich jetzt
natürlich mehr gedanken darüber mache
ich dankbar bin
es ist gerade mal 14 37 und mein magen
knurrt wieso ich kann
wie gern sie richtig gerade essen lecker
förderung des high-tech food borne für
ein youtube video musik gerade dieses
genre treu in mund nehmen und erspielte
aufstocken weil die schnecken flucht
habe wie ein vorbildlicher ramadan wenn
das war gerade echt hart zwar ein guter
geschmack im mund aber ich hab nicht
unter geschluckt hat aber schon regeln
gebrochen ich weiß es nicht
juni wenn ihr jemand noch im gang ich
habe eine neue erkenntnis mit der
schnitt gerechnet habe ich bin so
motiviert dinge zu tun die sonst die
ganze zeit liegen gelassen habe heute
meine wäsche gewaschen und bett gezogen
ich habe in unserem briefkasten und
finnland würde endlich dran gemacht
unser hausmeister das nicht hinbekommen
die wäsche gewaschen jetzt den
papiermüll runtergebracht ich habe ein
video gedreht ich habe heute morgen kurz
sport gemacht vielleicht hat man einfach
zu viel zeit weil die ganze zeit in der
ich nicht esse mache ich halt auch ein
graben aber gut ich habe alles geschafft
werden wollte ich mache den fehler und
schaut jemand anderem beim essen zu ich
hatte gerade die allerbeste ibs ist
nämlich gerade acht uhr ich habe noch
eineinhalb stunden zeit bis sich
fastenbrechen darf und jetzt gehe ich
kurz zum späten und hole mir schokolade
es ist jetzt 20 uhr 47 noch 45 minuten
und meine mitbewohnerin back mir einen
kuchen backen kuchen ramadan hat der
erste schluck und viele meinten komm
auch pünktlich zum fastenbrechen
meditieren ich glaube ich muss meine
hose aufmachen
das ist meditation gleich gibt es kuchen
für die nachwelt schon wieder so müde
aber ich möchte mich schlafen gehen dann
zwei schon wieder aufwachen und vor
allem könnte ich die ganze zeit das
essen anstrengend vergangenheit vanessa
hat gut vorgesorgt meine neue erfindung
karamell mit tortilla chips und seit ich
geht immer habt eine ramadan hose die
muss ich jeden tag ab 21 uhr 6
vor dem schlafengehen gibt es natürlich
noch unser kleines gewebt und dieses mal
bete ich wirklich also das gebet was ich
in meiner kirche gelernter weiter
unseren himmel geheiligt werde dein name
dein reich komme dein wille geschehe im
himmel so auf erden eine regelrechte
morgen aufgewacht und hatte so einen
schlechten geschmack nur deswegen ich
versuche nicht zu schlucken
eine sache noch ist für heute auch mit
kopfschmerzen aufgewacht und ich weiß
nicht ob welchen lauf des tages nicht
eine tablette nehmen wäre indes nicht
weggeht
ich versuche erst mal darüber selber
hinwegzukommen heute ist der allererste
tag an dem es unter menschen sind und
ich bin sehr gespannt ob ich das genauso
locker alles durch viel wie zu hause wo
mich keiner ablenken kann mit essen und
trinken das ist so eine qual von subway
auch noch nie gehört ich sterbe
guten appetit mittagessen
[Musik]
die erste challenge habe ich bestanden
mittagessen mit menschen und dabei nicht
gut gemacht oder
ich informiere mich jetzt fünf minuten
über den islam die eben einer neuen
lieblingsseite der glaube wird durch die
tat gesteht auch die wird abend eine
warme mahlzeit zubereitet aber viele
genießen er die atmosphäre im
fastenmonat und das zubauen weine der
familie und den freunden und legen
weniger wert auf viel spaß lege sehr
viel wert auf die schweiz aber das liegt
vielleicht auch daran dass meine familie
nicht bei mir ist und bitten einfach
dessen trio nahm bornheim und
abgeschieden die sonne rausgekommen und
meine kopfschmerzen sind einfach
eingegangen von denen ich habe keinen
schluck getrunken nichts gegessen ich
weiß nicht was mein kapitaler dabei hat
sich selbst geheilt
der feierabend wie das dürfte kräftig
kräftig nach favorit war einkaufen und
der größte fehler den du machen kannst
hungrig einkaufen ich habe mich
zurückgehalten eines war siemens war
wieder mal einen tag geschafft
fastenbrechen der vaart treffen wird
gewünscht mit einer datei oder einem
schluck wasser durchgeführt
während das folgende vom propheten
mohammed überlieferte bittgebet
gesprochen villa um deinen willen habe
ich gefastet und an dich geglaubt und
mit deiner versorgung breche ich das
fast im namen allahs des alba herzigen
des gnädigen danke jetzt mache ich mir
glaube ich gedanken darüber wofür ich
dankbar bin mir ist aufgefallen dass
jedes mal wenn ich darüber nachgedacht
habe für ich dankbar bin kam jedes mal
sachen spinnerten gedanken denken wir
dann ach ja stimmt dafür bin ich auch
sein bart und das finde ich es gut dass
werde ich plätze da nach dem ramadan
experiment noch weiter machen sich in
jeden tag fünf minuten nehmen und
darüber nachdenken wofür man dankbar
dass ich denke ich bin dankbar für
kinder schokolade
wer jetzt einfach schlafen gehen und um
233 wieder aufstehen und main gebiet
machen und dann weiter gute nacht die
letzte ramadan nach
[Musik]
an dieser tat irgendwie viel zu schnell
vorbei gegangen ich war heute morgen
beim zahnarzt dann bin ich zu studio
gefahren und habe geschnitten gehungert
gehungert gehungert rückenschmerzen
bekommen und jetzt bin ich schon wieder
zu hause und es ist 20 uhr fünf ich habe
es in anderthalb stunden einfach mal
vier tage lang geschafft dann ist es
vorbei in eineinhalb stunden kann ich
wieder essen trinken wartet wie ich will
noch viele ich will kein vergessen ich
habe heute meine zweite challenge
bestanden nicht ganz so wie sie glaube
ich gemeint war aber doch schon
bestanden
ich wollte einfach zu essen kaufen und
nach houston suchen körperlich kaum auf
da werde ich jetzt kauf ich essen was
man irgendwie schlecht wird oder wo
kriegen habe ich mir fünf euro in die
brusttasche gepackt und als dann jemand
kam mit dem becher und nachklänge
gefragt ob ich 5 euro rein gemacht und
die person hat sich so gefreut und ich
habe mich super gefreut weil die sich
gefreut hat und das war echt gut war
wirklich ein gutes gefühl ich sagen noch
nie hat mir schmeckt der feiertage wir
essen beschreibt ich hab's mir auch
verdient
ich habe es geschafft vier tage lang zu
fasten und das war gar nicht mal so
einfach ich war mir immer darüber im
plan was der islam ist und was diese
region so mit sich bringt aber mal
einzutreten in diese welt und dass man
selber auszuprobieren das war echt mal
was ganz anderes allein dass man sich so
viel über den ramadan gelesen hat hat
mir so viel geholfen diese religion viel
mehr zu verstehen auch wenn es moslems
nicht wissen nicht wie besser verstehe
ist ein gutes gefühl für mich zu wissen
dass ich jetzt besser verstehe natürlich
kann man sich nach vier tagen sagen dass
man eine religion versteht oder
irgendwie den hintergrund oder warum man
dieser religion auch volk aber es
wirklich um ein guter schritt in diese
richtung negative erfahrung im ramadan
der hunger ist schon ziemlich hart und
der durst auch es ist glaube ich einer
der größten talente die man sich selber
erstellen kann denn dein körper möchte
die ganze zeit trinken und essen und du
vergessen dass und dein körper verstehe
aber nicht warum und darf schaltet sich
der geist ein und das war auch eine
krasse erfahrung was der geist mit dir
machen kannst du bist zu dick in der
lage zu dem du dachtest das ist niemals
schaffen und am ende des tages wenn man
etwas ist ist man glücklich
ich kann es wirklich jedem empfehlen
sich mal dieser religion zu öffnen etwas
mal auszuprobieren dass diese religion
praktiziert und für sich die erfahrung
heraus zu ziehen man kann nicht am
anfang sagen ramadan ist doof wenn man
viel ausprobiert hat learning by doing
wenn du etwas verstehen möchtest musst
du es ausprobieren mehr gibt wird für
mich zu sagen ich weiß dass in diesem
jahr viele youtuber den ramadan getestet
haben und ich jetzt nicht gehen sache
neu erfunden habe aber ich find's cool
es auch mal gemacht zu haben und es war
eine tolle erfahrung und wenn ihr
möchtet dass ich als da mal sowas teste
nicht nur food dann schreibt in die
kommentare
schreibt mir auch mal wie hier das video
findet ihr meinen leidensweg zu
verfolgen ich hoffe das kam richtig
rüber und dass sie spaß beim zuschauen
und nicht so viel hunger bekommen hat
und jetzt möglich bitten bei den dackel
tätern vorbeizuschauen denn sie sind der
grund dafür dass die vier tage lang
hungern musste denn auf ihrem kanal gibt
es ein video in dem nicht nur ich faste
sondern auch mirella und marcel von den
tätern und die türkisch und fräulein
chaos glaub ich auch dort aber auf jeden
fall unbedingt vorbei das video der
hammer geworden und da könnt ihr nochmal
andere ansichten zu diesem ramadan test
sehen nicht nur meine fresse sondern
auch anders
gefressen und auch wieder das kamera
gibt es auch noch ein video zu dem
ramadan experiment also schaut er auch
unbedingt vorbei
grüßen sie ganz lieb von mir und dann
will ich sagen sie muss beim nächsten
mal wieder da kann wieder etwas nicht
will und ihm fahre und mein tattoo wir
kommen bald also stay tuned uns immer
noch und so